The first trailer for Ant-Man and the Wasp
just dropped revealing a ton of cool new characters
and details we can look forward to seeing
in the Ant-Man sequel.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I'm breaking down the new trailer
and explaining some easter eggs, wicked details
and other stuff you might have missed!
If you're new to my channel I do regular comic-book
movie videos, and to celebrate the first Ant-Man
and the Wasp trailer, I'm kicking off a new
superhero giveaway for all my subscribers.
I've got full details on that giveaway later
in this video.
Ant-Man and the Wasp begins in the aftermath
of Captain America: Civil War.
At the end of Civil War, Cap broke out Ant-Man
and the other Avengers who were locked up
in the Raft prison.
And in Ant-Man and the Wasp, it looks like
we'll find that the authorities have caught
up with Scott Lang, putting him under house
arrest.
It's pretty clear though that once Hope van
Dyne and Hank Pym make contact with him again,
Scott isn't going to be at home very long.
Hope and Hank are on the run themselves.
In fact, Hope blames that on Scott's Civil
War antics which might mean that their research
has come under scrutiny, and suggests why
Hank is using Pym particles to shrink down
his building into a portable piece of luggage.
The new mission that Hank and Hope contact
Scott about is their plan to bring back Hank's
wife, Janet van Dyne, from the Quantum Realm.
In the first Ant-Man movie, Hank explained
that during their mission to deactivate a
bomb, Janet, who was the original Wasp, went
subatomic when she deactivated her regulator
to get inside the bomb.
Though Scott went subatomic at the end of
that movie, he managed to return, which is
why Hank has been researching how they can
go to the Quantum Realm to bring back Janet,
who in this movie will be played by Michelle
Pfieffer.
And we might just have our first glimpse of
their journey into the Quantum Realm in this
shot.
The creatures around them look at lot like
Tardigrades, aka water bears, which are real
eight-legged micro-animals and are about half
a millimetre or 0.02 inches long at their
full size.
We don't know yet if this is the Quantum Realm
itself or just an interim stage where Hope
and Scott shrink down their new craft until
they reach the subatomic level.
The Quantum Realm has appeared briefly twice
before in the Marvel Cinematic Universe, first
at the end of Ant-Man and then again momentarily
in Doctor Strange when the Ancient One sent
Stephen Strange through the Multiverse when
he met her at Kamar-Taj.
Obviously, we've got to talk about Hope van
Dyne's The Wasp.
The trailer showcases an awesome power set
for the new hero.
In addition to Ant-Man's shrinking powers,
she can fly and shoot power blasts.
The blasters are a nice touch because, in
the comics, Hank Pym gave the Wasp wrist devices
which could produce electrified blasts that
she named "wasp stings".
And I just love how Wasp shows she's a literal
blade runner in this very cool slo-mo shot
of her running down the side of these knives,
which echoes Ant-Man's gun-running antics
in the first movie.
And when the Wasp throws the Hello Kitty pez
dispenser, it's another cool callback to the
first movie when Ant-Man turned a Thomas the
Tank Engine toy giant-size.
On top of that, the Hello Kitty nod also adds
a little Deadpool vibe, especially given that
the popular Marvel character could be joining
the MCU if Disney's deal with Fox goes ahead.
Now, you'll need to look very carefully, but
we do get a super-brief look at the villainous
character Sonny Burch played by Walton Goggins,
and he appears to have stolen Pym's miniaturised
building!
In the comics, Sonny Burch is the chairman
of Cross Technologies and, in Ant-Man and
the Wasp, it seems he could be trying to steal
Pym's secrets to either get revenge for or
take advantage of the demise of Pym's former
protégé Darren Cross in the first movie.
And that looks like the reason we get the
return of Giant-Man, who we see towering over
the boat, presumably to recover the stolen
property.
The trailer also gives us a quick tease of
the new villain Ghost who's played by Hannah
John-Kamen.
In the comics, Ghost is actually male and
is an elite hacker who can make himself invisible
and phase through objects.
And that might be what's going on here where
we can see an arm flickering and phasing in
and out of view.
The comic-book version of Ghost uses his abilities
to attack and destroy corporations and I wonder
whether the MCU's Ghost could be connected
to the villainous Hydra?
You might recall that Hydra agents attended
Darren Cross's presentation in the Ant-Man
movie and one of the attendees, Mitchell Carson,
managed to escape with a vial of Pym particles
before the building exploded.
So, perhaps Ghost could be working for Hydra,
and it's also quite possible that she's working
together with Walton Goggins' character Sonny
Burch.
The trailer also gives us a quick peek at
Laurence Fishburne who's playing Dr Bill Foster,
aka Goliath.
In the comics, Dr Foster is a scientist who
worked for both Tony Stark and Hank Pym, and,
when he became familiar with how Pym Particles
worked, he experimented on himself, creating
his giant-sized alter ego, Goliath.
He's traditionally a good guy, so it's quite
likely he'll team up with Scott, Hope and
Hank.
However, while the trailer doesn't reveal
a lot about Dr Foster, the way it's edited
may imply he could be connected with Ghost
or the bad guys at some point.
By the way, appropriately enough, the music
in the trailer is called "Ants Invasion" and
is by the British band Adam and the Ants!
So, did the Ant-Man and the Wasp trailer get
you hyped for the movie?
And were there any other cool details or easter
eggs you spotted?
Make sure you leave a comment below about
the trailer and subscribe for a chance to
win a cool Ant-Man Funko Pop.
If you enjoyed this, remember to like and
share, and hit the notification bell to get
all my new videos.
You can also check out more of my Marvel and
other superhero videos by tapping the screen
here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!